i'm gabby davis and i'm a jewelry
specialist at jared the gallery of
jewelry and today i'm going to be
showing you how i clean both a diamond
engagement ring as well as a beautiful
amethyst statement ring as well
both of these rings here i would call
extreme cases normally there's a lot of
lotions from people who aren't removing
their rings when they're applying their
lotions or their hair products so for
the most part when a ring comes in
needing a cleaning it just more so has
like a hazy look to it or maybe some
slight caked up of soaps and lotions but
hair is definitely not something that i
see every single day
the very first step before i even begin
cleaning it is using the fine tip of the
needle to actually check the stones
looking at this ring here it looks like
it has been at least six months if not
longer since this ring has been cleaned
now with the style of disengagement here
which is called a split shank where it
has these openings along the side it
really has allowed a lot of this hair
and this build up to become caught in
these openings of the ring
so i'm going to start out by using my
tweezers and needle to be able to
extract all of this hair that has gotten
caught up in all of the openings and
crevices of this ring here the guest who
brought in this ring is actually a
hairdresser which really helps explain
why there is such an excessive amount of
hair and products stuck up within this
ring and how it has built up so much
so what i'll do is push the hairs out
from both directions i'll be able to go
in through that split shank in the top
push it down into the ring where i'll be
able to gather it all together with the
tweezers to be able to pull this out
it looks like the reason all of that
hair is kind of staying and clumping
together within the ring is more than
likely due to all the other products
that she comes into contact with her
being a hairdresser like styling creams
and conditioners and everything that
she's using because as i'm pulling out
these hairs they are really like gunked
and caked together it's not just loose
strands of hair they are all compacted
together
not only has it gotten caught up in the
openings where it's actually visible
while it's on her hand but as well as
the part of the ring that's called the
undercarriage so that opening up
underneath between the actual setting
and your finger has become completely
caked up as well
so with the amethyst ring one thing that
i do have to be cautious about is being
a little bit more precise with using the
tweezers or using the needle versus on a
diamond ring is the amethyst is a bit of
a softer stone so i just want to make
sure that i'm not rubbing this metal up
against the stone to risk scratching it
with this amethyst ring and the way that
it's set down into the metal
it doesn't leave much of the stone
exposed up to the top which means there
is a lot of space for things to build up
within this ring it wasn't until i took
the needle actually around the inside
crevices of the ring that i noticed all
of the hair that was coming out of it
so i start with using a toothbrush to
remove the rest of the debris caught up
in the ring and then i realized that i
can't quite get into those tighter
spaces within the ring so i grab a
jewelry cleaning brush which actually
just has really fine hair like bristles
that make it a lot easier to be able to
get into those tight spaces
after checking all the stones and
pulling out all the debris i take it
over to our polishing wheel the abrasive
powders that are in that compound is
what will actually work to remove all of
those surface scratches and leave the
ring with a nice shiny finish so after
polishing it there's a lot of the
remaining compound on the ring so that
is when i'll bring it over to the
ultrasonic cleaner the solution that's
used in the ultrasonic it's mostly water
than just mixed with a mild alkaline
type solution that helps break down the
polishing compound that's on there as
well as any other buildup that's on the
ring the alkaline solution is gentle
enough to be used on the precious metals
like the silver is gold but it's
powerful enough to be able to break down
that polishing compound as well as
shampoos conditioners lotions soaps
other things that are built up onto
jewelry
since the ultrasonic solution is so hot
i am using a pair of tongs to both place
the ring in there and pull it out of the
solution as well
what really helps clean them in the
ultrasonic is not only the high heat of
it but also the
tiny sound waves or vibrations that go
through the liquid which is what helps
break down all of the residue on the
ring
by removing a lot of the buildup before
actually putting it into the ultrasonic
saves time from it having to soak in
there leaving it in there for extended
periods of time can actually cause the
stones to come loose
with the diamond engagement ring i let
this one soak for about three to five
minutes
since it's not quite as durable with
high heat i only let this one soak in
there for about a minute
so now to finish off i'll bring the
rings over to our steamer which is just
high pressured extremely hot water which
is used to get off any of those last
little bits of hair in this case or any
other debris that either myself or the
ultrasonic missed out on
one thing that can happen when you do
have a lot of build up stuck in a ring
is that can actually act like a glue
just because we don't want that pressure
to be so high that it is able to push
out those stones and have them falling
out
so a few tips that i have for keeping
your rings looking good in between
professional cleanings would be to make
sure that you're removing them anytime
you're doing things such as cooking
gardening applying lotions getting into
the shower washing your hands so one
thing that i do recommend is bringing
your jewelry in to have it
professionally inspected and cleaned at
least every six months which is actually
a free service that we offer at all of
our jared locations where we will check
your stones as well as give it a deep
cleaning